il ya huit ans en perdant cette finale
de coupe du monde on a perdu notre
dignité
l'esprit de notre peuple est en train de
mourir mais toi tu peux changer les
choses
j'ai demandé à youri de coudre ça pour
toi
les way et c'est comme ça que les gosses
de riches m'appelait pour se moquer de
moi non les jantes appelé comme ça quand
tu joues avec le jingle s'admiraient ton
jeu et là j'ai compris que tu avais
quelque chose que je n'avais pas il y a
des années disco quand je suis passé
professionnel je rêvais de jouer avec le
thing
celui qui ferait se lever les foules
dans les stades
mais quand la chance s'est présentée à
moi j'ai douté et ça a signé la fin de
ma carrière
mais pourquoi parce que j'ai perdu ma
confiance
tu sais le doute peut transformer le
jing a en quelque chose de dangereux
mais tu dois être plus fort que je les
et edico qu'en plein de montirat des
méchancetés sur toi et ton football tu
ne dois jamais avoir rendre à bâle
je sais j'ai compris